she found alcohol an open alcohol
bottle I'm sorry all right go ahead and
sit down right there for me okay
yeah trying I don't want you to fall
don't do that don't do
that well my team leader was taking the
or I kind of heard him like slurring you
know and she was trying to get him to
like repeat his order we couldn't hear
him so I start yelling at him cuz he was
not answering and open the back door and
soon I open the back door you can just
see him like nodding and know and I went
up there and I tried like pushing his
head and I tried like yelling at him to
wake him up and he wouldn't wake up then
I looked over and I seen the bottle that
oh
yeah
um um I don't know it's a stick Shi so
uh but it was on yeah
yeah he was asleep when I got up there
and he's been as like about 15 minutes
now it's no longer so this is a silly
question but I just have to ask it in
reference to like a possible DWI
investigation when you took the keys out
did you get in there and turn them and
take them out M you
did Hey Brother Albuquerque
Police Albuquerque Police hey man you
doing okay love
you Albuquerque Police Department I'm
officer Toni I need you to step out of
the car and talk to me okay come
on I want you to be
that so again I am officer Toni with the
Albuquerque Police
Department I am a police officer with
the Albuquerque Police I need you to
step out of the
vehicle come
on come
on I'm
with
hey man I need you to step out of the
car and talk to
us okay go ahead and take off your seat
[Music]
Bel what's your
name what you mean what's your
name
Hey
Brother Hey Brother
Hey hi I'm officer Toni with the
Albuquerque Police Department I need you
to step out
man go ahead and take off your seat Bel
for me okay was fine okay thank you I I
appreciate you working with us
okay I'm trying to be respectful to you
okay but I need you to step out of the
car
man reason we're here is the cashier has
caught you
hi
know reason I stopped you okay is or we
we didn't stop you reason we're over
here is the manager of waterburger
called us and told us you were
asleep behind the
wheel and she found she found alcohol an
open alcohol
bottle okay so I need you to step out
and talk with us
man take your seat Bel off get Stu out
of the
vehicle
[Music]
Hey
Brother Hey man hi I'm officer toon yes
go ahead and take off your seat belt and
step out of the
car my God okay so take off your seat
belt step out of the
car no I love that I love that you're
right there okay when I ask you to step
out of the car I need you to step out of
the car it's clear that you're obviously
Intoxicated by some measure I could
smell alcohol coming from you no okay
take off your seat Bel step out of the
car I'm not going to listen listen I'm
not going to ask you again take your
seat belt off and step out of the
car
now just you know you're detained for
aing a DWI investigation take off your
seat belt I thought that so
Beau you need to listen to us take the
Bel off and step
out go beautiful let's go take off your
seat belt get out of the car I'm officer
Toni with the Albuquerque Police
Department
no I I'm
not I don't care if you're not
interested when I ask you to take your
seat belt off and step out of the car I
need you to do that okay
I we can talk out here but I need you to
take off your seat belt and get out of
the car true so let's do
it right
[Music]
now
little thank
[Music]
you all right come on buddy step out
let's step
out you're on right now you're detained
for DWI
investigation again listen listen to me
we got called by the management here at
waterburger saying you fell asleep in
the Drive-Thru okay you had open bottles
of alcohol in the vehicle and your car
was on so you were no I I understand
come on and I'll explain to you it again
but I need you out of the
car thank
you sorry all right yeah I
don't okay why don't you come back over
here to the back of your car for me
right back over here where my partner is
I don't back over here I don't
understand well we're going to explain
it to you so walk back over
here do you need medical to come check
you out no no
okay my partner say
you're
contain alol car I'm
sorry cuz you were in a car that was run
in I was not trying to drive the car I
me are you okay sorry no
um
yeah
yeah lean on your car I was not trying
to anything you know how about you can
you sit down yes all right go ahead and
sit down right there for me okay yeah
come trying to I don't want you to fall
don't do that don't do that you don't
touch me keep your hands for yourself
thank you okay goad and sit down for me
okay be careful careful of course of
course do you have a driver's license on
you I I do okay can you grab it for me I
can't
why why can't you grab your
license do you have your license I do
okay go ahead and grab it for me it
might be in your wallet in your back
pocket say Okay grab your
wallet it's in this pocket right here I
understand what you're saying let I need
to see your
ID so go ahead and grab it for me can
give me one minute yeah go ahead just
give me one minute one minute yes sir
thank
you like you can see him like kind of
trying to order like you see his head
like pop up just a little bit mhm 1045
to
912 and like on the head to like I can
get you the girl that took the order too
but like I was hearing it a little bit
and you would like you can tell he was
sling his words a little bit and she
kept like getting yelling at him I was
like what's wrong you know and she's
like I can't get him I answer me back so
I started yelling at him and I even went
out there as soon as I opened that front
car that that back door that customer
was like it wasn't me cuz like I was
yelling at him
like like there I go okay probably the
most intoxicated guy I've seen behind
the wheel yeah tell off on the phone I
cannot believe he's still asleep I
turned his car off I opened his door
like at least three or four times I went
in his car yeah all right Mr Alfredo yes
all righty sir so I've been extremely
respectful to you expect the same in
return okay yes again I am offer toon
with the AL Police Department of course
yeah so right now you are going to be
placed under arrest for suspicion of
driving while intoxicated okay and also
hang on hang
on me out you're also going to going to
be under arrest for driving a vehicle
without I was driving the vehicle I
watched
it okay do not attempt to fight or flee
her force will be used against you this
entire interaction is being recorded
you're going to you're going to put me
under
arrest so what I need you to do is turn
around place your hands behind your back
okay well then please please you're
going to you're going to put me under
rest that's okay I need you to stop okay
let go of me
please understand let me understand give
me give me I will let you talk later
okay I'm just holding on to you so you
don't fall okay you can barely balance
yourself you need to throw up hey
Alfredo how can I Alfredo stop I'm
asking how can I you know get running
come on let's walk let's walk over here
okay I'll talk to you okay do you need
to throw up before we get in my
car you need to throw up let us know
too cuz I don't want it in my car
okay all righty be careful getting
in
all right go ahead and sit tight for a
second okay I'll come back and I'll
explain some things to
you we need the car toad but I want you
to come with me yeah like he's got like
four or
five
anysa on City what's
up
why I can't tell if that's open I think
that one's
closed holy
cow
and this
one's depends on how how high he blows
dude that one I think is still
close that one might be close too these
still
close 5 open 100
[Music]
m hey bud you doing all right yeah why'
you unbuckle yourself you what put sit
back down no yes you're in a car sit
down scoot over9 37 alast round you can
unbuckle yourself I'm fine okay you can
say that
okay is this your phone is this orange
I'm sorry is your phone orange no this
isn't your phone yeah okay you want to
take it with you or it is my phone yeah
stop I'm asking you a simple question
I'm asking do you want to take
your okay Well's my phone it's going
with you it's not going to be out with
you but it's going with you
okay
sorry it's right here I told you I got
it man
yeah